[Music]
the first time like I laid down the
guitar track and then play the fiddle on
top of this it make me have goosebumps
like this is something shamanic
you
[Music]
my name is nature gong-gong burger I am
a musician marina from China but I have
a Mongolian ancestry
so this our Mongolian fiddle we call the
money [ __ ] or in the English we can say
a horse hat fiddle
[Music]
throw singing is a very ancient and
traditional way of singing you press
your throat and you you generate one
sound but then you generate an over to
on the top of it within your mouth oh it
sounds like it sounds like to sound at
the same time
[Music]
if you read the Mongolian history it's
all about those brave warrior conquer
all around the world and they don't fear
death though you know that kind of
spirit
[Music]
I'm a tow people heavy-metal people it's
also like you know very manly you don't
give a [ __ ] you just do whatever you
want you know like this free free
experience definitely free experience
[Music]
people will say Oh while you are doing
Mongolian music they don't understand
the whole ancestry thing they don't
understand your own culture identity but
at the end of day I love the Mongolian
culture and that's all what it matters
[Music]
take him